- People don't understand, and you know,
that's the thing I want
you to clip, that part,
because people don't get it.
I've lived my truth.
(sirens blaring)
Yeah!
you got your prospective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeta music)
- So how can I make more stuff for myself
when I haven't found
anybody they can create
the content for the family?
- Because you're using ego
perfection and judgment
to limit your scale.
- Do you do the same thing?
- No, I'm the reverse,
the reason I'm a monster
is I don't tell them to do anything
'cause I think volume over
my subjective quality.
There's a very specific reason,
it's very interesting, I'm a very--
- Put that one on his Instagram.
(laughs)
- That's exactly what's
probably gonna happen
and it's, to your point, it's
a very smart observation.
A very specific reason why I popped and am
continuing and will continue
to pop in a different way
is I value the volume over the perfection
because I know that there's,
because even if you hire me and we come in
and do a 7.9 of your 10.
- [Justin] Mhm, right, right,
I see what you're saying.
- It's a net-net game.
'Cause I know how to scale.
Because if you, and I'd like you to,
when you come and visit
my dad's liquor store
10 minutes from your house,
that big building I built, Wine Library,
this 40,000 square foot
double deck wine store,
it was because I know how to scale.
This insanity from zero to
150 million in seven years
is scalability and
creators struggle with it
because, and especially
when it's your own subject,
that's what blows them all away.
This is me and I don't watch anything.
Right?
- It's true.
- I don't watch a single thing.
- So once he walks away.
- So who does the editing?
- They do.
Now, the one thing I have
creative control over
is my Instagram right now
where I will write the copy,
I write all the copy, and I will
not post things they send me
'cause I'm not feeling it.
And at our best, and
we're still not there yet,
I want to title to the
me me stuff at the top
because I'm good a copy,
it's how I am good.
- [Justin] And you engage.
- Every single, like, when I DMed back,
when I heart a comment,
100% if it's GaryVee it's,
that's why I created the
Team GaryVee account.
You guys could create a family
account and have her run it.
You see what I mean, but Gary, that's me,
that's why I created Team GaryVee.
That's why I build up DRock
and all the other people
for scale, I'm not scared to lose them,
I want to put them on.
I'm all karma, I'm all good,
I'm gonna give you every
best piece of advice.
What I'm telling you and
you'll appreciate this,
I'm glad the way this conversations going
'cause I would assume in a family dynamic,
just promise me one thing,
that you're making your
decisions for yourself first
and then for her second and
then everything will play.
- Well I put the family first.
- Then that's fine can.
Can I tell you something
that I really believe?
People who put their family first
at the expense of their happiness
always in the long-term lose.
- But that is my happiness.
- Then you're putting
your happiness first.
- Okay, I see what you're saying.
- Got it?
And for me I do the same thing,
look at my Twitter bio family first,
I believe the way I'm gonna
bring the most happiness
to my kids is by showing them
what a happy life lived is.
Like, everybody's got their own way.
So that's great, so how
do you fit it all in?
Whatever feels right on making sure
my kids and wife are happy and I'm happy
to the best of my ability
and never over judging myself
in a one day, one week, one
month, or even one year period
'cause life is long,
And I'm not trying to
check a box for the camera
or for my parents or for anybody else.
And that's where I see a
lot of families losing,
people are posturing for everybody else.
They're worried about, you
know how much judgment I get
for my work lifestyle, plenty.
- I'm sure, yeah.
- Plenty.
And I'm like, listen, and
you know, I'm a funny guy,
I'm like, you know,
you've got a sense of me
because you can see me, it's
not like I'm like fuck you,
it's like, yo, I really
understand why you think that
but you don't know me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You don't know what's
going on in my bedroom.
Like, do you know many people
come home at six o'clock
and check the box but are
like alcoholics in a man cave
or like don't give a shit or not paying,
like so that's how I balance it.
Out of peace of mind that
my intent is pure as hell
and that life is long.
I actually think the sooner
they can accept judgment
and know how to with it right the better.
I actually the better, right?
Like if you teach em self
respect and empathy and kindness
and like if they learn
how to deal, like better.
'Cause that's who I am,
all I'm D's and F's,
I don't where my, that's my
prized possession by the way,
I don't know where it is
right now, my report card,
that's my you know why?
- Is that it up there?
- There we go, you know why?
You wanna see a report card from,
you wanna see a New Jersey report card.
This is my prized possession
and I'll tell you why,
because it allowed me to get judged.
I was a loser by this system,
this is my high school for
years, D's, F's, D's F's.
I was taught adversity
from the get, right?
I think it's the advantage.
I look at minority females, I'm like,
if the world actually understands
what's really going on with the internet,
I actually think it's
going the other way now.
I think the whole world's flipping.
Like I really believe that,
like goosebumps believe, right.
Like, these are goosebumps.
I believe it because I think adversity
is the foundation of success.
- I was doing stand up
comedy for along time in L.A.
And I was bigger than
you were probably were
probably in 2008.
- I believe you.
- I commented on a video
that I didn't like it,
you commented back to me,
it was a negative comment
towards you like you
were loud or something
and I have never forgotten
how sincere I thought that was
that you commented back to me
and you were nice about it,
you just said, maybe it's
not for you or something
and I felt really ashamed 'cause I'm like,
I was kinda mean, I never forgot that.
It was 2008, I never told you that.
That was both multiple types of mediums.
And you put me in my place then.
- And think about how,
you don't know what
that just meant for me.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
Every word that just came out of my mouth
is based on the same shit.
I can't wait to run into you guys and like
and like tomorrow, a bunch
of times but in seven years
you're like that .01 was
it, I know I'm right.
You know crazy this to have the
internal happiness to be able
to take a negative comment?
Like, you can't imagine
what that meant for me.
- [Justin] That was 10
years ago you did that.
- Because people don't understand,
and you know that's the thing
I want you to clip, that part,
because people don't get it,
I've lived my truth, you know.
- I used to want to dislike you so much.
(laughs)
Because got the best of me
because I was mean to you
and I was probably a big,
'cause that was a comedian,
and people jumped in and
they were they were like,
so I was ashamed that I said this to you
and your response to me was
just like something so authentic
and years later I wanted to dislike you,
I mean, this was, not now.
- I totally get it, I totally get it.
- But then 10 years ago, I was like,
this guy's great, man, this guy's great.
- I love it.
- He introduced me to you too.
- Because, you know, we're so much alike.
The intensity, the vibe.
- I totally get it.
And so many things are,
you'll appreciate this,
I don't think I'm so great,
I think my parents are so
great and America's so great,
that's what made me.
So it's the reason I have
bravado and confidence
but the reason I have humility is
it's why I'm so passionate
about you guys winning
'cause that's what you're
gonna give a shit about.
- Are you rolling?
What's great about Gary is that he cares,
that's it, how about that.
You care a lot.
- I care a lot.
- When you have so much
love and you're good
you're literally like if I
was to man up to like draw it
I'd be like, well,
here's all these hearts,
I don't need them, right, yeah.
All right, take care,
you're welcome, take care.
(electronic music)